let's go next to Lucas from
Massachusetts Lucas welcome to the
program
if you're feeling better I'm feeling a
lot better yeah
glad to hear it okay so here's what I
was going to talk about please the
tremel yesterday had a tremel thought I
noticed that this this information is a
lot like the covet virus and that will
never eradicate it we can take measures
to bring it on under control and we
should but doing zero info like zero
code but isn't sustainable if that makes
any sense I'd love to hear what you
think yeah I mean listen but nobody's
doing zero covet anymore I don't know I
mean like sure I'm friends with him for
a while yes right uh but
when I look on Facebook I still see a
few people I'm friends with who seem to
be saying we should be doing something
close to zero covid and everybody wear
masks forever everywhere and all this
different stuff it's it's just not going
to happen you know and I try to focus my
conversations on harm reduction minimize
issues ETC and I do think that we we
just have to be sort of realistic but
yeah you can only do I mean listen way
more Republicans die do we now know
because way fewer Republicans got the
vaccine what were we going to force him
to get vaccinated no but it's it's like
you provide the information you do what
you can
yeah but like with this information I I
know you support media literacy courses
and I agree yeah I just think it's very
important because
you're not suppressing all the possible
information like dot cut off the
internet would not be worth it
um media literacy would really work
almost like a vaccine yeah no you're
hopefully inoculating people from
falling for fake news
yeah and like
never got a media literacy course at
school because I'm out of high school
now and in college but
um yeah that's just what I wanted to say
and like I said I'm glad you're feeling
better and I enjoy the show Lucas
powerfully said I appreciate the call
all right take care all right you two
we're gonna take a quick break but we're
still taking calls so if you're holding
on to talk to me don't hang up and then
we'll get right back to the phones in a
moment